There's one other point about query gates that's worth mentioning before we move on, and that is that when we're designing and analyzing query algorithms,
we don't worry at all about how
query gates are implemented.
It's assumed that these
query gates are given to us, and the difficulty of building
them isn't our concern.
You can think of the
query gates themselves as being the input if you like, and it's not our job to create the input, we're just trying to
solve a particular problem
given the input. Of course, when f is a function
from one bit to one bit, there are only four possible choices,
and it would be easy enough
to implement any one of them, but in general, for functions
with many input bits,
it could be extremely difficult to implement query gates
for those functions.
To be clear, this isn't
to say that the issue of how query gates are
implemented isn't important, but rather that it isn't considered
to be part of the cost
of a query algorithm.
This is consistent with the idea that this isn't really
about practical computing or actually building circuits per se,
it's about working within
a theoretical framework that tells us interesting
things about computation.
We will have more to say about this when we make the jump from this model to a more standard model of computation, and that's mainly what the next lesson,
Lesson 6, will be about.
Now let's turn our attention
to quantum circuits.
For quantum circuits, we're going to change the
definition of query gates to make them unitary.
We want to be able to make
queries within quantum circuits and for them to operate
linearly on quantum states
so that we can effectively
make queries in super position.
It might seem like we're moving
the goalposts, so to speak, by changing what we mean by a query in comparison to what we just
saw for Boolean circuits,
but there is justification for it that we'll discuss in more
detail in the next lesson.
For now, it's just a definition.
Specifically, the
definition is as follows, given any function f of
the same form as before,
meaning that it maps n bits
strings to m bits strings, the query gate Uf acts on n + m qubits
and is defined by the
action described here on standard basis states.
We'll see a figure
representing this definition in just a moment, but first, let me make clear the notation
that's being used here,
and that is whenever we
use the symbol for the XOR as an operation between two
strings of the same length,
we're referring to the
bitwise eXclusive OR, and here you can see an example.
In the definition, we have that both y and f of
x are strings of length m, so this string right here
represents the string we get
by XORing those two strings
together, one bit at a time, and here's the diagram
explaining how these gates work.
The top n qubits correspond to
the argument of the function.
And when they start out
in a standard basis state, cat x in this diagram, that standard basis state
goes through unchanged
and gets echoed as part of the output.
The bottom m qubits correspond to the output
of the function f, and when they start out in
any standard basis state,
cat y in this diagram, what happens is that the
output of the function f of x gets XORed onto the string y.
This is what happens for
standard basis states, and if we wanna know
what happens in general for other quantum states, we
use linearity, as we always do.
A reason to define query gates like this where we echo the input and we use the bitwise XOR for the output
is that these gates are always unitary for any choice of the function f.
This is, in fact, a
deterministic operation.
And if we were to express it as a matrix for any choice of a function F, we'd get a permutation matrix,
meaning one with a single one in each row and in each column, and all other entries equal to 0.
And permutation matrices
are always unitary.
In fact, for this operation, we'll get that the operation
is its own inverse, so Uf dager equals Uf.
If all we wanna do with these
gates is to evaluate f of x for some string x, that's easy,
we can just set y to
be the all-zero string. So when we take the bit y's eXclusive OR, we end up with just f of x.
Here, by the way, you can see the notation that's used to denote the all-zero string.
It looks like 0 to the power M, but that's not what it means.
It means the string of zeros
having length equal to M.
When we're talking about
strings as opposed to numbers, exponents typically mean that we repeat that string
some number of times,
so this is 0 repeated m times.